(wind howling)
(mouse clicking)
(beeping)
(inspirational instrumental music)
- [Announcer] We are the paradoxical ape.
Bipedal, naked, large brain.
Long the master of fire,
tools, and language,
but still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable,
yet filled with optimism.
We grow up slowly, we hand down knowledge,
we empathize and deceive.
We shape the future
from our shared understanding of the past.
CARTA brings together experts
from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who
we are and how we got here.
An exploration made possible
by the generosity of humans like you.
(warm music)
(upbeat electronic music)
- So as Alison mentioned,
we started talking
about imagination and in part
because I direct this center,
the Arthur C. Clarke Center
for Human Imagination
here at UCSD where we're trying
to understand imagination
and then think about ways we
might more directly address
imagination as a phenomena.
And so then this comes
around to thinking about,
how might we think about imagination
and its role in human origins?
And I think we have
maybe at least two ways
to think about this that
we're going to be exploring
in today's program.
So one is, what are the
dimensions of our imagination
that give rise to our humanity,
and you know, these
particular characteristics
that allowed homo sapiens
to create our anthropic era.
And another is the critical ways
in which our imagination creates knowledge
about things that are beyond
our ability to experience them.
Whether it's about far off places
or far off time both in
the future and in the past.
And so in particular, I'm very interested
and curious about how we
imagine something as distant
from our experience as
the origin of humanity.
But it begs the question,
just what is imagination?
So imagination, it's kind of a mushy term.
It can mean so many things
that it might end up
meaning almost nothing.
So is there a way we
can start to think about
how we approach understanding
the phenomena of imagination?
So we might start by
looking at what smart people
have said about imagination.
And so the kind of poster
child for a smart person
is Albert Einstein, right?
And so Einstein said quite a few things
about imagination over his
career and just one of these is,
imagination is more
important than knowledge.
Knowledge is limited, but
imagination encircles the world.
And so Einstein might have
been a pretty smart guy,
but this actually says almost
nothing about imagination.
It's very inspiring, but
the only think I really take
from this is that
imagination is extensive.
So that's a characteristic
I can draw from it.
So maybe someone who has a
little more stakes in the game
can give another kind of
shading of imagination
and Maria Montessori, an educator,
so imagination is probably
a very important thing
for an educator to say something about.
And for Montessori it was
imagination does not become great
until human beings, given
the courage and the strength,
use it to create.
So she actually, that's kind
of, she's kind of coming down
a little negative on
imagination in this quote.
You know, that creativity's
important to her,
but imagination might be
a little bit frivolous.
And Carl Sagan, you know,
another kind of smart person
gives us another kind
of even, maybe another
kind of warning about imagination.
That it's gonna take us to
places, to worlds that never were
which sounds kinda scary, right?
But without it, we can't go anywhere.
So he kind of redeems imagination.
That well, in the end, we
probably actually need it
even though we've kind
of, it's flown us off
to someplace that doesn't even exist.
But I kinda start to turn to some things
that I think start to
shed a little more value
on imagination, and of course
the first one I pull up
is an artist, you know Mark Twain who says
that you can't depend on your eyes
when your imagination is out of focus.
And now to me this start to
actually give us something
valuable to think about,
because it starts to connect
the imagination to our senses.
And so there must be some relationship
between experience and imagination.
And so I think Oliver Sacks
kind of puts a number of pieces together
that I think are really
critical to think about.
That every act of
perception, is to some degree
an act of creation,
and every act of memory
is some degree an act of imagination.
So we start to connect perception, memory,
and imagination together
as interrelated phenomena
that are quite important.
And so if we want to start to find,
how might we think through
exploring that connection?
And I think art is a really valuable place
to think about this.
I think of art as this kind
of laboratory of imagination
for a number of reasons,
and one mentioned here
by the philosopher George Raymond.
But art, for both how art is made,
but equally as important
for how art is experienced.
And so as an example we can start
by looking at this fresco
in the Church of St. Ignazio
in Rome and start to trace
through maybe a couple of ways
in which the imagination is
working to make this a thing.
So first of all we note that
it's this trompe l'oeil.
It's using this perceptual trick
that was figured out called perspective
that tricks us into thinking
that something is a space
when it's just a flat plane.
And they do it here by
extending the trompe l'oeil part
is because they're extending
the architectural features
with this kind of imagined
architectural feature.
And it's also then connects
that imagined extension
of this church into this
entirely imagined place
called heaven, and so it
situates it in a story space,
which is this incredibly
powerful attraction
that we have to our
underlying cognitive need
to make sense of things.
And it populates that space
with a bunch of figures
that look a lot like the
kind of sweaty, smelly things
that are standing all around
us on the floor of the church,
but of course they're up there in heaven,
but all of it's just made from
these little dobs of paint,
right, these little
colored pieces of pigment.
But our perception doesn't pay attention
to the small detail differences.
We abstract from it an cohere it
into what we think is the
phenomena that it likely is
which is it's probably
like a person or an angel,
a fictional person.
And so artists always
exploit these capabilities
and deficiencies in our senses
to engage our imaginations
on so many levels.
And so we all know about how cinema works.
We don't actually see
things that are moving.
We're just seeing static frames
that are shown to us so quickly
and with some ordered
coherency between them
that we can't help but
think that it's a depiction
of something in motion, so
it's depicting something
beyond what it actually is,
and this has always been
a desire and an operation of art.
So in these cave paintings
from 30,000 years ago
the artists start to try
to develop methodologies
to show something that's beyond
the thing that's actually there
to show something in motion
with this static medium.
And by doing that they
are directly engaging
our imagination as much as
they're engaging our senses.
So art we can see is this collaboration
between our senses, our
memories, and our imagination.
Which is also just the equation
for reality itself, right?
And so if we want to start to think about
how we might understand that, you know,
we started to think about how
imagination is a phenomena
that takes us from one moment to the next,
that takes us from those
moments to the near future
and then takes us from that near future
to think about the far future.
We can also think of it maybe
as having different areas
that it kind of functions,
that goes from the neurological
to the cognitive to the social.
That takes us from thinking
about our personal fate
to our local, global,
and even cosmic fates.
So I follow the same mistake
that I just laid on Einstein
where imagination is
everything everywhere, right?
But within this now actually we have
a little bit of a rubric
that we might be able
to explore some things in.
And so later on today I think
you're going to be hearing
about a project that Alison is doing
that we're collaborating
on about thinking about
an underlying neurological
basis of human imagination.
And as we have said that there's this,
as Alison was mentioning, it
would be an interesting thing
to be able to think about human
imagination comparatively.
And so here's these great sculptures
by the Kennis brothers
depicting early homo sapian
and neanderthals and you know,
can we think about some ways
in which the homo sapian
differs in some capacities from
our cousins or early humans.
You know, we know from early
humans, we start to see
this artifactual record,
the Venus of Willendorf.
We see other examples that
go continuously back in time
and from other places
and even some examples
from very long ago.
And whether or not these are kind of,
we have always made little
fertility goddess figurines.
Or perhaps we're always looking
for fertility goddess figurines.
This idea that humans have
been making symbolic culture
for a long time is one
of the underlying things
that we think about with imagination.
And even now we start to find new things
that help to fill out that story.
So seeing that they're a neanderthal,
just things that we're now
attributing to neanderthals
as part of their symbolic culture.
So might there be ways besides looking
at the artifactual records to
think about human imagination
by looking more directly
at the underlying biology
of these things, and so
Alison is like a magician
as far as I'm concerned.
He has come up with these ways
in which he can do something
quite extraordinary,
which is take human stem
cells, and on the left
we have human stem cells that
have grown brain organoids
and on the right we have those stem cells
but they've been coaxed
to have neanderthal genes
that then express neanderthal neurology.
And so on the right we
have neanderthal brains
and so what we're looking
to do is then test them
in relationship to how what
kind of anticipatory responses
they may have to different
stimulating environments
and see what kinds of
differences they have.
And you can already see
there are some morphological
differences that are quite evident.
So not only looking at the
kind of neurological structure.
I wanna give a very quick
example of something
at a little higher order to thinking about
at the cognitive structure
where we're looking
at other aspects that I think
are underlying components
of our imaginations and one
of them is spacial navigation.
And so understanding how you are in space
and what space consists
of has obviously been
a very important part of
most species' survival.
Here what we have started to learn
is that we have two mechanisms
of how we think about space.
One in which we're egocentric
and we kind of think the world
reorients itself around us
and one that's allocentric
where we think the world is in
a fixed coordinate space and
we reorient ourself to it.
We use both these mechanisms and in fact
when we switch between them
is a place where we really
have to open our eyes
and kind of re-understand
what our relationship to the world is.
Now it turns out those
two kinds of experiences
excite different parts of the brain.
And we can sense that with EEG devices.
So we've been working with
a team of neuroscientists
to develop virtual words that
have kind of novel structure
where we can try to directly switch you
into going from one navigational
scheme to the other.
And we do that by, well
you're seeing an example
in a video of this experience.
You embody one of these avatars.
You have a navigational task
you have to do in this environment
and we radically change
it in a very uncanny way
to try to keep you highly stimulated
in your spacial response to
making a coherent experience
from this environment.
But of course, I'll maybe just wait
'til the last clip plays here.
And doing that people have to,
we sense what kind of
navigation they're using
and then try these tricks to trick them
to switch them into the other.
But you know, I also want us to be aware
of this idea that we
only, it's easy for us
to study humans in a certain way,
but we can also fall into
this kind of circular trap
of human exceptionalism, you know,
that we're the only
thing with imagination.
So I think certainly we are
are exceptional in many ways,
but trying to characterize and understand
where it makes sense
to kind of think about
what's different from
us versus other species
is a critical issue, so
for instance I know my dog
has this amazing imagination.
You know, every time I
pretend to throw the ball
it imagines that I've thrown the ball.
And I've done this with
that dog 1,000 times
but there's obviously something
about the anticipation
of throwing that ball
that it's more important
for him to fail 1,000
times because it allows him
to succeed just a little bit better
the other few times that I do it.
But you know, we may not even, you know,
imagination maybe there's
even roots in things
that don't even have neurological systems.
So this is a white blood cell navigating
through a complex environment
of red blood cells
trying to chase down a
virus and if you watch
how these microbes move,
they seem to at times
look to cut them off at the pass
and anticipate their moving
one way versus the other.
And this is without any kind of neurology.
So imagination is this
tricky thing to think about,
just as all these other
phenomena like cognition,
consciousness, to try to think about,
we first of course
bring to these questions
our own experiences and understanding
and we have to be quite imaginative
to kind of think outside of that.
And it can get us into some problems.
So for a long time I think one
of the prevailing sentiments
of neanderthals was that they
didn't have a symbolic culture
and so this is from a recent exhibition
at the Australian Museum that talked about
that they lacked the depth of symbolic
and progressive thought
displayed in modern humans.
And that was before kind
of a number of artifacts
were discovered that may
have kind of start to make us
have a more complex
relationship to that question.
So in my work I try to think about things
that might be able to
augment our imagination.
And we're starting to do a lot of things
with artificial intelligence.
The fourth time around that
artificial intelligence
is suddenly the next big thing.
But we're working with ways to think about
how to model aspects of human imagination
through things like genetic
algorithms and neural nets
and we bring to that a kind
of human-centric approach,
but in the end the effective
measures may cause us
to really come up with a
completely different kind
of imagination than a human-based model.
So the last thing I want to
talk about in relationship
with this is then how
stories kind of work in this.
And so we're the Arthur C. Clarke Center
and an aspect of that is
the value of science fiction
as this way to kind of cause us
to radically think about new
kinds of human conditions.
And so some of the work we do with that.
This is an example of a project we did
with a science fiction
author, Kim Stanley Robinson
and a performance artist Marina Abramovic
where we took Marina Abramovic methods
which take things that
usually take a few seconds
and try to extend them into experiences
that last over a few hours.
And Stan Robinson's work
who's trying to get us
to understand what it would be like
to experience a phenomena
that lasted 1,000 years
like the travel to another star.
And the ability to kind of
put these two temporal shifts
in relationship to each other gave people
a far more visceral understanding
of the experience of temporality.
And so these things like
stories and performance
and ritual art may have been things
that we think really discovered
once we started to extend
the day into the night
and then think about what
we do with that nighttime.
We come up with ways to make better sense
out of everything that
happened in the daytime.
And so these stories, why they sometimes
were completely fictional
and talked about worlds
that never were, sometimes
they actually brought sense
to things that we previously
wouldn't have connected.
And of course as we move forward in time
we've just come up with
more and more proliferations
about those campfires
and more and more ways
to tell stories around them.
Now it's often thought that
language came before art.
But I have another theory that
I think language came about
so that art could be
critiqued and explained.
(audience laughing)
And this is the artist
Joseph Beuys, he's trying to
explain art to a dead rabbit.
So Picasso kind of gave us this idea that,
you know, he said that we all
know that art is not truth.
Art is a lie that makes
us realize the truth.
And so this is the
astonishing thing, I think
that our imaginations, our
ability to conjure meaning
from occurrences has given us this ability
to create all that we've created.
And so how this happened
and where this will take us
couldn't be more important or
more exciting to think about
and I look forward to digging into that
for the rest of the day, so thank you.
(audience applauding)
(warm electronic music)